- Hello friends, my name
is Paul Meighan here
with my friend Anna Bouchet
and we work on Amazon S3.
Our job today is to bring
you up to speed on everything
that the S3 team has been
working on over the course
of the last 12 months since
we were all here at re:Invent
together last year.
Now I've been doing this session
for a number of years now
and I think this is my last year doing it.
And every year I threaten to do a demo
and every year the marketing
team talks me out of it.
But not this year.
This year we have come up
with the most complicated
demo we could think of
and we brought in our best
engineer to help run it,
and it's gonna go great.
So that's the plan.
In fact it's so complicated,
I need a few volunteers from
the audience to participate
and we're gonna take a video
as I gather some names of our volunteers.
I need two. And all you
gotta do is yell out a name
or yell out a fake name.
It works either way.
So who is open to volunteering
for our demo today?
Yes, Matt is our first volunteer.
Another one over here.
What?
(indistinct)
Indra Neil.
All right, Matt and Indra
Neil are our two volunteers
in our re:Invent session today.
Anna, do we have that?
All right, so we're
gonna cover 35 launches
over the course of the
next 60 minutes together.
I have six topics to take
you through really fast.
We're gonna do security, durability,
we're gonna talk about S3 Express,
which is our high performance storage.
We're gonna dive deep into
S3 objects and the S3 API
and then round it out with
metadata, tables and vectors.
That's the plan.
Now every year we key this
course in as a 200 level session.
And the reason that we do that is
because we just cover so much
ground here in the what's new.
We just don't have time
to dive deep into every single feature.
But Anna and I will stay
after the session in the
hall for as long as it takes
to answer any questions that you have.
We're committed to giving
you the detail that you need
to take some of this home with you
and put it to work next week.
We've also tried to build as
many links to source material
as we can throughout the deck.
And so you can get that once it posts
to YouTube after the show.
So that's the plan and
the clicker's working now.
So let's get started.
So we're gonna start with security.
Security is the most
important thing we do at AWS
and it always will be.
So it's fitting that we're gonna start
with the new security content this year
at the top of the session.
We're gonna talk about access controls,
org level controls and encryption
here over the course of
the next few minutes.
Now, when you're managing access to S3
and you just have a single
bucket and a single application
or client, it's pretty straightforward
once you kind of get the hang of IAM.
But as you add more and more clients
and more and more buckets to the mix,
things get a little bit more complicated.
You wanna maintain lease
privileged permissions
to each one of these buckets.
And so you have to tailor
sections of the policy
for all the clients that need to come in
and access your data.
And since every bucket
likely has different
clients coming in to access
different pieces of data,
you really want to tailor
each policy to each bucket.
And what you end up with is a whole bunch
of different policies
that you have to juggle
and manage across many buckets,
which is complex and becomes even harder
when you have to manage changes over time,
'cause you have to now
start swapping in policies
and management becomes
more and more difficult.
And so to simplify this, a couple
of weeks ago we launched
tag-based access controls for S3.
This allows you to control permissions
to your S3 resources using
simple policies in conjunction
with resource tags.
And it simplifies things by quite a lot.
Here's how it works.
So here's an example of the sort
of policy fragment that
you can now use on the client side.
And you can see that this
policy is very simple.
It just says give access to
this principle to any resources
that is tagged with a blue tag.
Very simple fragment, much simpler than
what we saw on the previous slides.
And then to grant access, all
I need to do is tag my buckets
with the appropriate tag
values and access is granted.
If I wanna make changes over
time, I can just add a tag
to grant access and remove
a tag to remove access.
So it's much simpler, much
easier to reason about
than juggling policies
across my resources.
We've also given you some
new APIs to help manage this
that are also better
than what came before.
We have a bucket tagging API
in the current namespace,
but we added some new APIs
that look much more similar
to what you're used to across AWS.
So we have an untag resource API now
that can remove a single tag off a bucket.
We have a tag resource API,
which can add a single tag onto a bucket.
And what's different from
these new tagging APIs compared
to what came before is
that single tag operations.
Previously you had to
replace the entire tag set,
even if you only want to
change one tag on the resource.
So this is much safer and easier to use.
Additionally, we have a list all my tags
or list tags for resource API as well
that spits out this handy dandy JSON list,
showing all the tags
that you have on a given bucket.
So that's tag-based access controls.
We think it simplifies things quite a lot.
We went through general purpose
buckets here in this example.
But this works for all S3
bucket types, directory buckets,
access points, table buckets,
tables, vector buckets, vector indexes,
which we'll talk about
here in a few minutes.
So that's what we have on access controls.
Now every year we come in
and talk about these useful
features on the security side
that we'd like y'all to turn on and use.
We always recommend that you turn features
like block public access
on at the account level
so that any new bucket you create in
that account automatically
has public access blocked by default.
But more and more customers
are running AWS organizations.
And so what we've done is we've
leveled these two features
up to the org level now.
So now you can apply block
public access out at the org
or OU level and this 403 context feature,
this provides additional context
and information about
your access denied errors.
It used to only work
when a request started
and ended within an AWS account.
That's also stretched
out to an entire org now.
So you get those improved error messages
for any request within an org.
So you're gonna see more
of this from us over time,
adding more and more org-level content.
And we're happy to get these
two org level controls out
to you here just over the last few weeks.
So that's our org level controls content.
And just wanna say a few
things about encryption.
Now, one thing that is
true about encryption
is that it's constantly evolving.
Here you see all the encryption types
that we've launched over the years,
satisfying different use cases
and there's different
reasons why you would want
to encrypt stuff in different ways.
And we added another encryption
type just about a week ago,
and that is PQ TLS,
which provides post quantum encryption
for TLS, for data in flight.
Works across all S3 endpoints.
If your client supports PQ TLS method,
it'll automatically take that path,
automatically encrypt in that way.
And this, while quantum
computing isn't here yet,
this protects against that capture now
and decrypt later threat vector
and just gets the quantum computing threat
sort of out of the way moving forward.
So PQ TLS is the latest
addition to the sort
of S3 encryption portfolio.
Now in the security space
over the last few years,
one thing that we've done is
we've updated the defaults.
We did it with block public
access, which is now default.
We did it with access control lists,
which are now off by default.
We did it with encryption at rest.
And our thinking on this is that we wanted
to update the defaults with
best practice recommendations
so that you start from a
place of best practices.
It's really important for
security in particular.
And the way that we think
about it is for those features
that have smaller, more niche use cases,
we'd like to have those off by default.
They're opt-in so that you
don't have to think about 'em
if you don't need them,
which most of you don't.
Now, SSEC, which is an
encryption type that allows you
to pass in an encryption key generated
by you outside of KMS is
one of those features.
And so a change that we've
made here in November
is to give you the ability
to just turn this option off
so you can update your
bucket configuration
to not accept SEC objects regardless
of what the client says.
This is an optional tag
that you can flag now.
An optional property
that you can turn on now,
but in 2026 we'll update the default.
So any new bucket created
will have SSEC off by default.
So some updates to encryption.
A big update to access controls
with tag-based access controls
and then some new org level controls.
That's the update that I have for you
on security this year from 2025.
So that outta the way.
Let's check in on our demo, Anna.
- All right. Hello everyone.
As Paul mentioned,
we have a very complicated
demo ahead of us.
Many things can go wrong.
Hopefully none of them will.
And to kick it off, we took a video.
So as Paul was talking about
the three security improvements
I used Amazon Transcribe
to create speech-to-text
representation of this video.
We captured the names of
our volunteers here as well,
Matt and Indra Neil.
Here's what I'm going to do next.
I also downloaded about
700 customer stories
from AWS public website.
I will rename all these
files to have unique names
so that we can no longer determine
which one has the transcript of the video.
I will upload these files to a S3 bucket,
which I created ahead of time.
And then I will tag with color tag
some of these files at random.
I will be using shades of
purple for my color tags.
All right.
I have a script. I'll start with a script.
Oh no.
- [Paul] Oh, no.
- [Anna] Is it familiar
situation? Access denied.
So frustrating.
But no worries, no worries Paul.
This is a hundred percent
staged failure to show
how easy it is to debug
access denied issues
with enhanced error messaging.
So what my script is doing,
it's trying to list my bucket
to confirm that it is empty.
But it got access denied,
and so from this message
I can see the actor,
I can see the permission
and I can see the resource
that is being accessed.
I can also see that access
was denied explicitly via bucket policy.
Let's quickly hop to S3 console.
So in my bucket policy, I
have denied for any principle,
for least bucket action if
my principle environment tag
does not match my bucket environment tag.
Policies like this, they
can be very suitable
if you want to achieve a
highly dynamic access controls
because in policies like
this you can just manipulate
bucket tag to make this deny go away.
One thing I forgot, mention,
if my principle doesn't
have environment tag,
like all the principles
in my presentation,
the default value of re:Invent 2025
will be used in its place.
So let's give it a try.
I navigate to the properties
console, I'm adding a tag.
It is environment tag with
the value re:Invent 2025.
I'm saving changes and
I'm also making sure
that bucket ABAC configuration
is in the enabled state as
this is what enacts my tag.
Now I can go back to my
script and restart it.
Oh no, it is not empty.
Let's go back to my bucket
and let's empty it first to
make sure it is indeed empty.
All right, going back
third time is a charm. Yes.
Okay, it'll take us a moment
to upload this 700 object
and we will check on
this upload in a second.
- All right, thank you.
That was the pick a card,
any card part of the demo.
Now we're gonna talk about durability.
So Esri is famously 11 nines durable.
And my plan was to get up here
and sort of dive deep
into how we achieve that.
But I just don't have
time to do that today.
So if you click on one link in the deck,
I would click on this one.
Links to a YouTube video with one
of our senior engineers really diving
into how we achieve 11
nines of durability.
It's a really interesting topic
and I encourage customers
to really understand it,
'cause it just helps to build against S3.
Just in short, there are
really three things that we do
to get you 11 nines of durability.
The first thing is we do
end-to-end integrity checking
to make sure that bits
stay good as they flow
through the system from our
front door down to storage.
The second thing is we
always store data redundantly
on multiple storage devices
so that we can tolerate the failure
of multiple devices with no impact
to the integrity of your data.
And the third thing that we do
is that we sweep back through
and audit the durability of
your data over time to make sure
that your data stays good and
is not corrupted by a bit flip
or something like that.
So the high level, those
are the three big things
that are going on within S3
and we're executing billions
and billions of check
sums every single second
in order to achieve these three things.
This third one, the
durability audit is something
that we've heard about
from customers quite a lot,
especially customers
that run video archives
or other sort of high-value
digital archives.
These customers often have
very important digital assets.
They need to go back and validate
that they're good over time.
And so for that use case as well
as just a general capability,
to give you a general capability
to validate that we have
what you think we have,
we launched some new
data integrity checks.
What this feature is, is it allows you
to efficiently run check
sums on data at rest in S3
to validate that in fact
your data is as expected.
You run this out of our
batch operations system.
You just submit a job,
submit a list of objects
to go check some.
We'll quickly process that
and give you back a report with
all the checksums of the
objects in that manifest.
Now this is far more
efficient than you can achieve
on your own because you don't have
to spin up any compute
to process checksums.
You just give us a job.
It doesn't affect the tiers
if you're running intelligent tiering.
So cold data will stay cold
to save you on storage costs
and it works with glacier objects
as well without you
having to go orchestrate
and manage glacier restores back to S3.
Okay, so great feature for validating
the durability of your data within S3.
Next thing I wanna talk
about is S3 Express.
So the way to think about
S3 Express is it's sort
of a stripped down lean mean version of S3
that is just built for low latency.
It's able to achieve
single digit millisecond
requests very consistently.
It's typically used for
high throughput use cases.
Some very big training workloads
on S3 Express right now.
But customers are coming up
with all interesting ways
to leverage low latency S3.
I've heard a bunch of interesting examples
of that here at the show this year.
We updated S3 Express in a number of ways
over the course of the year.
We did a price cut reducing
the cost of S3 Express by up to 85%.
We raised the TPS limit
or the transaction per second limit,
up to 2 million reads per second
and 200,000 writes per second.
We introduced an object rename
API in S3 Express buckets,
so that you can anatomically
rename individual objects
and we added access point support
to give you more granular control
over permissions to S3 Express.
So a bunch of interesting
important updates
to Express here over the
course of the last year
and we're very excited
about the trajectory
of this service heading into next year.
Now the next thing that I want to cover
for you is S3 Objects.
So I'm gonna talk a little
bit just about the S3 API
and some things that we're doing
in order to help you manage lots
and lots of objects across your buckets.
Now last year we launched
conditional rights.
This is sort of a long time coming
but what conditional rights are is
that it helps you in multi
writer scenarios to make sure
that one writer doesn't
accidentally overwrite
the work of another.
And it comes in two flavors.
You can do a put if absent
using the if absent condition.
This is where you wanna write an object
and you wanna make sure you
don't overwrite an object
if it turns out there's an
object there to overwrite.
And we also have a put if match condition
where you pass in a checksum
with your put request
and you will only overwrite an object
if the object you're
about to overwrite matches
that checksum in the put request.
This is also called a,
referred to as a compare
and swap operation as well.
So we put this out last year
and the response from
developers, which is amazing.
So many of you took these
new APIs and built on them.
It's one of our fastest adopted features
and recent memory for sure.
We're actually doing millions
and millions of conditional puts today
in just a short amount of time.
And so we decided to kind
of double down on conditional
rights and added two more.
First we added conditional copy.
This works the same exact
way with the same conditions
as conditional put.
Allows you to lock down a bucket
to make sure that there's no way to write
any data into your bucket
either using put or copy
unless it has the
appropriate conditions on it.
We also added conditional delete.
Conditional delete works like
put if match in that you pass
and a checksum in with a delete request
and the delete will only go
through if in fact you are deleting
what you think you're deleting.
The checksum has to match.
This is for sure a
durability best practice,
something that we do internally
when we're deleting data,
sort of part of our, how we
achieve that 11 nines story.
And it's an example of
us sort of externalizing
the stuff that we are doing internally.
So two new conditions that you can use
with both copy and delete.
Now I also wanna talk about big objects.
So there are use cases out there,
especially with video
and seismic and genomics
that are generating really big objects.
And so it was time for us to go ahead
and lift the maximum object
size, which we did yesterday.
So now you can run really big objects.
Previous limit was five
terabytes, now it's 50.
It's not really anything else
to tell you about this feature
other than you can run really
big objects right now, now.
But this is a tough one
for us to implement.
Changing in variance
in S3 is a lot of work
and so we're happy to get
this out there, especially
for those customers that
need those huge objects.
Another thing that's
been true in recent years
is that you all are managing more
and more objects in your buckets.
Not uncommon for
customers to have millions
or even billions of
objects in an S3 bucket.
We really give you two methods
for managing large groups
of objects and those are object tags
and batch operations,
which we talked a little
bit about already.
On object tags what we did this year
is we did a price cut back in the spring,
reduced the cost of object tags by 35%.
So if economics were holding
you back from using tags,
you should take another
look at the math on that.
We also did a bunch of
updates to batch operations.
We'll talk through those in just a second.
But just real quick,
for those of you who aren't
familiar with batch operations
or BOPS as we affectionately
call it internally.
Batch operations allows you to process
many, many objects at scale.
And it does this very reliably
because we handle all of the
retries and job management
and all the undifferentiated
work that you have
to do in order to do anything
a billion times over.
It's also very flexible.
It comes with 11 sort of
prepackaged operations
that you can execute against your data,
like adding and removing
tags, copying data,
adjusting object lock
settings and a bunch more.
One of those operations is actually firing
a lambda function, which
gives you a whole bunch
of flexibility on top of
those pre-canned things that you can do.
So we made a bunch of
updates to BOPS in 2025.
We added a no manifest
option for batch operations.
So instead of passing in a
list of objects to go process,
you can just point a batch
operations job at a bucket
or a prefix and we'll
go process everything
in that container.
We also added, IAM roll
creation automation as well.
So you can more easily get a job going.
We raised the scale of each job
so you can now process jobs
up to 20 billion objects
and we increased the
performance of batch operations
by up to 10 x here just this week.
So batch operations in
2025 got some nice updates.
It's easier to use,
more scalable and faster
than the last time we
were all here together.
So that is batch operations.
And these are the updates
that we had to objects.
So just to take a very
unnecessary side quest
in our complicated demo,
we're gonna hand it to
Anna to actually show
what what BOPS looks like.
- [Anna] All right, so we ended up
with uploading 744 objects
all successfully uploaded to my bucket.
All of them renamed to some unique names
so that we can no longer know
which one is the transcript.
And some of these objects are
also tagged with color tag,
which is just some random shade of purple.
So now what if you want
to assign a different
color tag to this object
and most importantly, what if
you want to assign it at bulk?
This is where a batch
operations really shine.
In couple clicks, no manifest,
we can create a job just
by picking our bucket,
picking some match
criteria for the object.
For today's demo we will
be using zero three.
That's because it's December 3rd today.
And in couple more clicks
we can ask Paul also,
what color is his favorite?
- [Paul] Black.
- [Anna] Black, clearly.
All right. Black for Paul.
Now, we picked to start the
job as soon as it is ready.
We opt out of completion report
as we don't need it for this demo.
And as Paul mentioned
now we can also create
a new role that has all
the necessary permissions
to do tag re-assignment
for all the objects.
And that's it.
We submit this job.
We will check on its progress in a second.
It will take probably
couple seconds to complete.
And we are jumping back to Paul.
- And thank you.
So next I'm gonna talk a
little bit about S3 Tables.
S3 Tables gives you fully
managed Apache Iceberg
tables in S3.
We launched it at re:Invent last year
and the response from
customers was just amazing.
We got so much great
feedback, so much interest
and it sounds cheesy, but
the team really went home
from re:Invent just
inspired by all the interest
that came from customers.
And since then y'all have created more
than 400,000 tables in the system.
We're very happy about that
it's proven to be useful for you.
And we've done a lot of
work to mature the service
covering a lot of ground
in the first year.
There's actually more than
I can cover on S3 Tables
in this session that we've done this year.
It would just be the
S3 Tables, what's new?
And we've got a lot of
other stuff to cover.
But I wanted to show this slide just
in case there are folks
here in the audience
or that are watching that
saw the launch last year,
decided that they'd wait
for the service to mature a bit
before taking a second look.
I just wanna flag this for you,
'cause we've put a lot of development
in over the course of the last 12 months.
It's matured a lot.
But I am gonna kind of go through
some of my favorites here
in the next few slides.
Just give you a feel for the progress
that we've made on S3 Tables.
We introduced an Iceberg
Rest catalog endpoint
for S3 Tables buckets.
This allows you to communicate
directly with your tables
and manage them using
open source Iceberg APIs.
If you have a very simple
use case like with PI Iceberg
where you just wanna write
directly to S3 Tables
and skip having to go through
a third catalog system,
you can do that by reading
and writing directly
from that IRC endpoint.
We raise the table limit up
to 10,000 tables per table bucket.
We added sort compaction,
which rearranges the rows
in a table on compaction
to make your queries
faster and more efficient.
We did a compaction price
cut, reducing the price
by 90% and we added some new options
to the create table API
so that you can set schema on create.
So that's just a few
of the smaller features
that we delivered over the
course of the last year.
And I'm gonna take you through a few more,
but I just wanna take one minute
to about this concept of
tables as AWS resources.
Now this is a characteristic
that is unique
to S3 Tables compared to the rest
of the ways that you can run Iceberg.
Every table in S3 Tables is
a first class AWS resource,
which means it has an ARN.
And it paves the way, it
opens up a lot of options
for us in terms of the sorts
of features that we can deliver
to you because so many services
and capabilities across AWS expect
to operate on AWS resources.
Just a few examples this year
are table level CloudWatch and CloudTrail.
So you can get observability
down to the table level.
We throw events at the table level
that tell you, CloudWatch events,
that tell you when we compact your data.
Cost management tooling.
So you now have tables in the cost
and usage report and then cost explorer
so that you can understand
which tables are driving your bill.
KMS.
We implemented table level
encryption keys at a KMS,
so that you can assign a different KMS key
to every single table in a table bucket.
These are examples of features that
would be difficult if not impossible
to implement when tables
are logical entities
just defined in metadata
in a file in an S3 bucket.
A big feature that we had in mind
when we launched S3 Tables,
and that relies on this concept
of tables as AWS resources
and a feature that
customers started asking us
for immediately is table replication.
We launched this yesterday
and we're super excited to
get this out there to you.
This feature provides read-only replicas
of Iceberg tables that are in S3 tables.
Now we've done replication
for a long time,
we actually replicate more
than 150 petabytes a week.
And so to be honest,
I didn't think this was
gonna be a big deal for us
to add table replication into the mix,
but it is actually a different animal
replicating tables compared
to just replicating objects.
And I'm gonna quickly take you
through why here in a minute.
So you understand what this feature does.
Very high level when you
run an Iceberg query,
there's really two parts to it.
The query goes down and gets the metadata
and the metadata tells the
engine what data files it needs
to go read in order to satisfy the query.
And so naively, if we were
just to shift all of this over
to the replica side,
the results would look
something like this.
Because that metadata
is bit for bit the same
as the source side and it
still references those original
data files and this is
obviously not gonna work.
And so it's not really
metadata replication
that we're doing, it's a rewrite.
We're rewriting the metadata
for you onto the replica side
so that it's referencing local data files
so that your query can actually
do what it's supposed to do.
But we have to do more in order
to make this a reliable service
because our replication is asynchronous.
Not all objects are gonna
arrive at the same time.
And when a query comes in,
you don't want it referencing,
you don't want the metadata
referencing an object
that's not there yet.
That'll just crash and burn
and give your end users a bad experience.
The appropriate behavior
is for that query to hit
the most recent complete snapshot.
So that query results can be
successfully returned back
to your app, and then for the metadata
to be appropriately updated
once all of the data is over.
So that we're always giving you data
that represents the most recent
complete data set available.
So that's what this feature does.
There's a catalog
consistency element to it
and we're happy to get it out there.
So that's sort of our big,
one of our big launches
here at re:Invent this year.
The other big launch that we have
that we launched yesterday is a feature
that personally I don't
really consider S3 Tables
to be complete until we had it.
It's a feature that's widely adopted
on the general purpose side,
a feature that customers have
saved more than $6 billion
on storage costs with over the course
of the last several years
since it was launched.
And that feature is intelligence hearing,
which is now supported with S3 Tables.
It gets you automatic cost up optimization
for your data lake, reduces
storage costs by up to 80%.
And here's how that's achieved.
So for those of you who are familiar
with Intelligent Tiering
and from general purpose buckets,
this will look very familiar to you.
It's the same exact tiers,
same exact cost reductions,
same exact tier names as you
have with general purpose.
The way that it works is
that we tier data down
as it's not accessed over time.
So if you don't access data for 30 days,
we go down to the infrequent access tier,
which reduces your storage cost by 40%.
After 90 days, we reduce your storage cost
by an additional 68% in the
archive instant access tier.
This all happens automatically
without you having to do anything at all.
It's exactly the same as
with general purpose buckets.
The intelligent tiering that you know.
What's different is that in tables,
our compaction and table
maintenance systems are aware
of the underlying tiers.
And this is a characteristic that's unique
to S3 Tables compared
to the west of the ways
that you can run Apache Iceberg.
We only do compaction in
the frequent access tier.
Our compaction systems
are aware of the tiers,
and this prevents us from
accidentally tiering data up out
of these cold tiers.
And that reduces your storage costs
and protects the cost savings
that intelligent tiering
is delivering to you.
Additionally, as we're compacting
in the frequent access
tier, the reads that we need
to do against your data
in order to do that table maintenance
that we're doing on your
behalf, don't count against
that timer that I talked
about on the previous slide.
So if we have to compact a
few times over the course
of two weeks in order to
get you to the right sort
of properly maintained
table, you don't have
to wait another two
weak or another 30 days
after the last compaction to tier down.
You only have to wait
another initial 15 days
or however much you have since
the last time you read that object.
So very happy to get intelligent tiering
for S3 tables out there.
And again, it works specifically
for Iceberg, which is nice.
Now I've run through like a long list
of feature content here
and oftentimes when I do that,
especially in the analytics space,
customers ask me about
how we're also making
things simple for them.
And the big simplifier
that we've done this year
for S3 Tables is to add support
into SageMaker Unified Studio.
And we updated Unified Studio
just a couple weeks ago
to enable IAM-based one-click onboarding.
And I pulled this into
the S3 deck this year
because it really is
the easiest way to run
and interact with data in S3 tables.
You give a link now to jump off
of the S3 management console
from the detail page of
a table that you have.
You can jump straight
into a SQL editor right
from there with just a single click.
Once you're in Unified Studio,
you can also navigate off
and get access to our new
notebook that you can use
to process data in your
tables with SQL or with Python
or even with natural language.
So just a very, very easy way to go browse
and process and manipulate data in tables.
So those are our updates on S3 tables.
Again, very excited about the
trajectory of this service
and very happy with with the uptake.
And with that, wait, we'll
talk about S3 Metadata.
S3 Metadata is another launch
that we announced last year
in preview at re:Invent.
And what it does is it
automatically generates metadata
about the objects in a bucket.
We announced preview
last year at re:Invent
and in January we launched
what we call a journal table.
What a journal table does
is it records records
for all of the changes in S3 that you make
to a given bucket automatically
down to an Iceberg table
that you can query with standard SQL.
So as mutations are flowing
in, puts, deletes changes
to metadata, we're recording
those line by line in a table
that you can go query.
That was in January,
and then we came back in
July with two updates.
The first update to S3
Metadata was a price cut,
where we reduced the price of
that journal that we
just talked about by 33%.
We also added this concept
called a live inventory table.
This gives you a point in time
view of all of the contents
of your bucket at any given point in time.
Sort of a snapshot of the
metadata for all of your objects.
How it works is that the journal rolls
and it records all of the changes
that you're making to your data.
And every few hours we come in
and do what we call a coalesce,
where we generate this
inventory view of everything
that exists in your bucket.
And this is useful because
you can just jump onto
a SQL prompt, write simple SQL statements
to understand the contents of your bucket.
For example, this is just a simple query
that I wrote in Unified
Studio that allows me
to quickly get after all
of the objects in my bucket
that are greater than about
four megabytes in size.
So it is easy to see how it's
useful to go troll through
and find stuff out about
your data sets just
from a SQL prompt based on tables
that are generated for you automatically.
So that is S3 metadata, a price cut,
the journal and the inventory
and now we're gonna swing back to the demo
and check in in our uploads
and show you the stuff in the flesh.
- [Anna] All right, let's
get back to our job.
It completed successfully in five seconds,
which is fairly fast,
considering 700 objects
that it needs to go through.
It found 75 objects matching our criteria
as it indeed put a
color black tag on that.
And as we can also see the IAM role
was automatically created for us.
Now what I didn't mention
when I created my bucket,
I also enabled metadata configuration.
So now I have two tables,
both journal table and
live inventory table
and I can navigate to them
through S3 console as well.
These tables store data in Iceberg format
and we can use any Iceberg
compatible engine to query them.
As Paul mentioned, there is
a single click experience
to go straight to the Amazon
SageMaker Unified Studio.
In the query editor that opens,
we can just start exploring
our data right away.
For example, we can count how many objects
we created during this presentation.
We do it by querying journal table.
We know the answer. It should be 744.
Yep, that's right.
From this view, we can also
navigate to the data view
where we can examine
the schema of our data
and in one click we can also navigate
to the notebook experience.
In the notebook experience we
can use our natural language
to start writing queries right away.
For example...
Let's create a distribution
of updated keys per color tag value.
It might take a while to
generate the proper query.
It's a complex prompt
that we've given that.
And with that, Paul, do you
still remember your SQL?
- [Paul] Absolutely not.
- [Anna] What will we do
if gen AI doesn't generate it right?
- [Paul] Gen AI is gonna work great.
- [Anna] All right, we you got
our query, let's look at it.
It indeed seems complex to
me. Let's give it a try.
Okay. All right.
As I mentioned, we have black
and we have 75 objects tagged with black.
That's the color Paul picked.
The rest of the objects
are tagged with purple.
This is the color I picked
ahead of this presentation.
From this UI,
we can also navigate to different views,
for example, bar charts and pie charts.
So as you explore your
data, give SageMaker a try.
It is by far the easiest way
to start getting insights from your data.
- All right, so now I'm gonna talk
a little bit about S3 Vectors.
So I've been working on storage
and storage accessories
for almost 20 years now.
I'm really comfortable in the engine room.
I gotta say though, that like
working on AI over the course
of the last 12 to 18
months has been super fun
just because we're all kind
of learning about it together.
The technology's moving
so fast and it's been fun
and rewarding to kind of learn about it.
I'll admit that 12 months
ago, 18 months ago,
I would've been hard for me to explain
what a vector is, let alone how to use it.
And I bet there are people in this room
who are there right now
and don't quite understand
what a vector is.
And so I'm gonna very quickly
explain what a vector is,
what customers told us, sort
of why, what we were responding
to when we launched this product,
and then how this product
looks and how to use it.
So that's my plan for the
next 10-ish minutes or so.
So I have a list
of data points in my pocket
right now, on my phone,
which I'm sure all of you do too.
And each one of these data
points has a machine readable
name and a resolution or frame rate
and number of kilobytes in storage
and a bunch of other attributes like that.
But if I were to describe
one of these images to you,
I would not use those terms.
For example, if I were
to describe this image,
I would describe this as
a funny looking dog sitting
in front of chairs in an orange room.
And what I'm communicating
to you is the meaning
of the image and not its
physical characteristics.
Now, computers know all about
the physical characteristics
of our data, but they can't
directly calculate meaning.
Only we can do that.
And so what a vector tries to do,
and it tries to bridge that gap
because computers are
so good at processing
and calculating numbers.
What a vector is, it's simply a long list
of numerical values
generated by a specific type
of large language model
called an embedding model.
And these values represent
all of the characteristics
of that given piece of data.
So is there a dog in the picture?
Is there a chair in the picture?
Is it indoors or outdoors?
What color is the room?
And thousands of other dimensions.
And so we get this
mathematical approximation
of meaning that becomes
more and more closely resembling reality
as the science progresses
and the models become better and better.
And this gives us some
interesting capabilities.
This ability to mathematically quantify
similarity and dissimilarity.
Specifically what it allows us
to do is it allows us to
go through large data sets
that are otherwise unsorted and
arrange them into categories
that are meaningful for humans.
And we can do this by just
comparing the mathematical values
that we derive from vectors
between one piece of data and another.
We can calculate the
distance, which represents
the similarity or dissimilarity
between two data points in a data set.
We can also cluster data points together
and these clusters represent data points
that have a similar meaning.
And now when we load all of
this up into a vector store,
it becomes very interesting
because now we can go build applications
that very efficiently
calculate similarities
and differences and do
groupings across thousands
and thousands of different dimensions.
And this is a very, very powerful concept
and it's sort of the underlying
kind of driving force
into when you see agents sort
of behaving very human-like.
Now this sort of
multidimensional expression
of relative meaning is
often expressed on slides
and in three dimensions.
But that's only because it's really hard
to get 2000 dimensions
onto a PowerPoint slide.
But this multidimensional
space that is kind of created
by the math of many data
points that are vectorized,
we refer to as vector space.
And we can do interesting things
with vector space loaded up
with a bunch of vectors.
Specifically, if we
bring a new data point in
and we don't know anything about it,
we can learn a lot about
that data by determining
which cluster it belongs into,
like finding out what are its cohorts
across various dimensions in vector space.
To do that, all we need to
do is calculate a vector
for this new piece of data
using the same embedding model
that we use to create the vectors for all
of the other data points
in our vector store.
And we can then compare across
all of those existing data points
in order to find what
would be this new piece
of data's nearest
neighbors and vector space.
This ability to find and
identify similar bits of data
in terms of meaning is
called semantic search.
And this is the foundation of
how all modern AI systems retrieve
and interact with information.
And so you can imagine over the course
of the last 12 to 18 months,
as many of you have been
exploring AI, running prototypes
and taking AI-based
systems into production,
you can imagine sort
of the uptake in semantic search
deployment over that time.
And when stuff like this happens
customers come to us with
questions about storage.
And really two big storage questions that
we were fielding from customers
on this new data set,
this new vector data set.
The first is just what is
the durable, reliable storage
that I should use for this new data set?
What you're effectively
doing here is you're building
a new metadata layer on
top of your data sets
and it's gotta go somewhere.
Your AI-driven applications depend on it
and customers need that
reliable storage to host it.
Now this is a storage
overhead as all metadata is,
and it's a small amount of overhead
for like image and video data,
but for text it can actually
be a lot of overhead.
The vector data for text
data sets can actually
be more storage than the
underlying text data.
And this is sort of very interesting
because it just goes to show just
how much meaning is packed
into human language.
So that's the first thing is
customers just were asking us,
what is the right sort of durable,
reliable storage for this new data set
that I need to power my applications?
The second set of questions really
around the price performance curve.
Now, this is a question that we work
with all the time for
all storage products.
This trade off between,
fast storage at a high price per gigabyte
versus slower storage at a
lower price per gigabyte.
It's why we have a range
of storage classes in S3 from
S3 Express on the fast side
to glacier deep archive
on the slower side.
This range of storage along
the price performance curve
is very helpful to match storage
to the appropriate
application requirements.
Now, most of the semantic search
that's been deployed over
the last several years
has really been for hybrid search.
So taking semantic search
and complimenting the keyword search
that we've been doing for a long time now.
And for this use case,
there's really a low latency requirement
for the underlying storage.
This is because a lot of
times in this use case,
it's a human sitting in
front of a search box.
And if a human is sitting between...
If your application is sitting
between a human and the buy button
you need to ring every
millisecond of latency out.
But as AI has proliferated to more
and more use cases, there's this universe
of use cases that are
happy to trade off latency
for a lower storage cost.
Just a few examples of that.
Retrieval, augmented generation or RAG
is a technique that you can use
to add knowledge that's
specific to your business,
to the knowledge that's trained
into the big large language models.
It's what allows us to go drive agents
that know about our own
specific data and workflows.
A lot of times these
workflows are asynchronous.
You can send an agent off
to do a multi-step process
and oftentimes across much,
a bunch of text as well,
which as we saw in the previous slide
can be more expensive.
And so in this case it's
easy to envision cases
where trading off a hundred milliseconds
or so for lower storage costs makes sense.
We also have a bunch of
customers in the video space
that wanna run semantic
search against video.
And the next step in workflow is
to go recall video data from Glacier,
which is a multi-hour process.
So for these use cases in
particular very willing
to trade off latency
for lower storage cost.
In fact, that's the whole point
of glacier in the first place.
So, basically what we found
is talking to customers
is that on one hand we have
this universe of applications,
this growing data sets that we're looking
for reliable storage to host them.
And in the other hand workload's willing
to trade off latency
for lower storage cost.
And that's why we launched S3 Vectors,
which is a native vector store in S3
that reduces the cost of
vector storage by up to 90%.
It gives you latency in the
a hundred millisecond range.
You can store up to 2
billion vectors per index up
to 10,000 indexes per vector bucket.
Now normally when I'm out here talking
about a big new feature like this,
I have a whole bunch of knobs
and dials to take you through,
but I just don't with this
product, it's very simple.
It has some APIs that you can use
to update and manage vector space.
You could almost predict
what those APIs are,
not even knowing what the product is.
Put, get, list, delete.
And then importantly a query
API to go query vector space.
What's a very important characteristic
of this service is that it
scales from absolute zero
and you only pay for what you use.
There's no pre-provisioning.
It works just like S3 in that way.
And what's really powerful about,
for this use case in particular
and what's been really awesome
for my team is this means you can
do tiny little AI prototypes
using this vector store
and it costs you very little,
'cause there's nothing to provision,
there's no purchasing decision to make.
But if one of those prototypes
or experiments takes
off, you're kind of okay
because the vector store scales
with the characteristics of S3,
scales elastically, has a
durability, reliability,
all of that stuff that you expect from us
when you place data on our storage.
So that's sort of generally what it is.
It's the vector bucket
with some simple APIs.
Really quick before I
hand it back to the demo.
Here's just a quick overview
on how to interact with it.
It's just based on a simple
70-line python example.
So you take an image to
insert into vector space,
invoke an embedding model via
bedrock to generate the vector
and then insert that
into the vector store.
It's really three simple steps
and as you can see, it's quite simple
to plan out in Python
to actually run a query.
It's actually very similar.
Same thing, start with an image,
invoke the embedding model
again to calculate that vector.
But instead of inserting
it, I'm using it as an input
to my query passing that,
that vector in as an input
and then that'll bring back
to me the most similar
results in vector space
to that image that I use to query.
So that's how you build
against this thing.
Just a quick example
of how to actually use
the APIs, but we actually
expect most customers
to take advantage of it
via other AWS services.
It's already integrated with OpenSearch
where you can basically
use it as a cold tier
behind your hybrid search implementation.
So helping to reduce the cost
of those hybrid search use cases
that we showed on the left hand side
of the price performance curve.
It also, you can click through
and make it an option, use
it as an option in Bedrock
to create a knowledge base
which allows you to do
RAG and standup agents
and all of that good
stuff with your own data.
This is what's been really
impactful for my team
and I dunno, I could
talk about it all day,
but we have only a few minutes
left so we'll pass that back
to Anna to actually show what
this looks like, the demo.
- [Anna] All right, so
here's the challenge.
We have 744 objects,
but only one of them has
transcript of today's session.
So how do we search this
corpus of data semantically?
To assist with that,
we will be using Amazon
Bedrock knowledge base
plus S3 Vectors and QCLI agent.
For the knowledge base,
I created it earlier
during the presentation
as it takes quite some time to sync it
with a storage with my original data.
And I used Amazon Nova
Multimodel embeddings model
to create vector
embeddings out of my data.
And I'm using Amazon S3
Vectors to store those vectors.
Now let's quickly hop
into QCLI setup.
On QCLI when I started up,
it also comes with Bedrock
knowledge base MCP server.
I installed this server
from AWS Labs GitHub
and it's very easy to configure.
You basically just need
to provide your AWS
credentials and region.
This MCP server simplifies interactions
between agent and the
knowledge base in Bedrock.
Now I also created a
context file for my agent.
In this context file I give
some directives to my agent.
For example, for every question my agent
should first consult Amazon
Bedrock knowledge base.
It should also ask for
the knowledge base id
and I also give some hints to my agent
how to query this
knowledge base effectively.
I need to add this
context to my agent first.
And after I'm done with that,
I have a question of the day.
What are the names of two volunteers
at re:Invent in re:Invent session today?
My agent is asking about
my knowledge base id
as I instructed it previously.
Let's copy it.
Oh yeah, that was the wrong one.
Okay, here's the knowledge base id.
Now the agent tells me
that that's the query.
It's going to run.
This query looks good to me, so I approve.
Paul, what do you think?
- [Paul] It has to work at this point.
- Yay. Congratulations
Matt and Indra Neil.
Thanks for volunteering.
(audience applauding)
- All right, that's what we have for you.
35 launches in 57 minutes.
We really appreciate
you taking an hour out
of your re:Invent to spend with us.
Thank you for entrusting
us with your data.
It's a responsibility
that we take very
seriously on the S3 team.
And please rate the
session, provide feedback.
We read every single comment.
It really helps us to determine
what to bring to you every single year.
And so encourage you all to hit the app
and give us a rating.
Thanks a lot.
(audience applauding)